by reading the electrical signals of our
brains scientists have developed brain
computer interfaces or BCI's to connect
machines directly with our minds in the
past year a community of engineers
artists and makers has come together
because of open BCI an open-source
company based in Brooklyn by offering
affordable hardware powered by
open-source technology open BCI empowers
the DIY community to reimagine how we
interact with machines I've been
involved in open source hardware since
about 2008 practicing it using it trying
to design around it we started open BCI
which is an open source brain computer
interface platform this weekend we are
running our first hackathon this is what
we've been waiting for is to actually
have the tech in the wild and to be able
to teach people how to use it and to
bring people together people who have
experience with brain computer
interfaces people who have no experience
brain computer interfaces but everyone
has a stake in or an interest at least
in the space so it's just been really
exciting to have everyone come in here
and kind of demonstrating what all these
signals mean and how they can be used to
understand who we are in order to get
started with our Kint attach the six
boat double a battery pack to the open
BCI board next attach our electrode
cables to the board now it's time to
attach each electrode to the body the
brain muscle and heart's electrical
signals can now be visualized through
the graphic user interface
it's really awesome to see people
witnessing their own brain activity for
the first time you should see a
heartbeat even have a heart rate it's a
good so each time she blinks her eyes
you can see these these big spikes here
and see all those spikes
those are EMG artifacts electrical
muscle activity this hackathon er is
measuring his brainwaves associated with
concentration as he plays a computer
game our hackathon is work to control
each of these robotic toy spiders
through the power of their brain
activity little more theory this
hackathon er is controlling this robotic
arm using an EMG electrode when he
flexes his forearm the electrical
impulses generated by his muscles
trigger the robotic arm to move the
robotic arm itself is entirely
open-source and was printed with a 3d
printer in this demonstration each
hackathon er concentrates on one
independent command to collectively
utilize their thoughts and steer this
inflatable shark through the air
innovation happens faster when software
and hardware is open-source when people
can change it and modify it to their
desire I think what's really important
is presenting a tool both for research
and for learning people of younger
generations who can approach the entire
problem space from an inquisitive
perspective where they're like I don't
know what I can do with this yet but no
one really does this community of DIY
cyborg enthusiasts and innovators are
growing larger every day open BC I have
hosted hackathons all over the world to
encourage and foster the next generation
of BCI devices with the help of dreamers
makers and experimenters more
applications for this technology will
soon be discovered and for now we can
move a freaky inflatable shark with our
minds come on that is cool as hell want
more cyborg nation then hit that
subscribe button
you